welcome to this blitz game ya heah into
this video I hope it's linked in
starting but and that happens if here
request the game and then get some skype
messages that irritate you or cannot see
what ultrarunner here is doing king's
indian moon fault you putter Kings in
you ok going to try a new line with
should be three that's something that
I'm once in a while played an over the
board chest but mostly forgot all all of
it but hear this kind of maroc see bind
structure with c4 a difference always
welcome to me always feel that white
should be somewhat better if not much
better in many cases let's see well I've
got some pressure on the six but not
quite sure yet how to how to play it
exactly King edge one was this kind of
typical little improving move that might
be useful huh but what I what am I going
to do here what is the the right right
plan in this position I don't want him
to play d5 now at the moment that is in
fact not possible ok probably a 3 and B
form that does make some sense I guess
ok he tries to go to e6 button of course
are not going to trade i'm going to
retreat the night he's got less space so
i definitely don't want to trade any
pieces yep or let's say not not more
than it's necessary a six and so is
weakening the dark squares yet more huh
ok if i go here what are you doing 97
I'm taking your pawn c5 can be played
but then I just go back to see three
and I'm happy about the weakening of the
d5 square that was my idea Bishop d6 on
Knight b6 is awkward so he played c5 and
I'm just dropping back tried to jump to
d5 mmm so if i go to d5 now i think he
cannot take this right the night on e
six doesn't have any squares where does
it go now I mean to d4 but this is
almost at javits I actually overlooked
the f8 square huh okay it's not a
problem is it's still a very good
position for white but I I simply did
not it did not take this into account
that he can go down okay so what is his
plan here c5 probably right you know
Knight e5 264 was my original intention
I wonder if green a5 as a move trading
Queens and I he will trade and play at
five I don't know if this is so great
probably want to keep the Queen's on for
the moment f5 at the moment at least he
has to why can't play that if i take it
f5 i take he takes it to probably rookie
to Queenie to Queen 85 this is a bit of
a liability down but f5 I can play 96
and rook this 7ef is terrible for black
from a structural point of view my look
quite good
yeah that's interesting i was thinking
about this Bishop a six now who gauge is
coming but I wanted to go here anyway
well let's say this is the what's the
second idea of course connected to the
whole thing yeah so I'm going to take
now I guess yeah I'm going to take and
how to continue Bishop d3 is the simple
way to play yeah I guess simple is good
keeping the night yet established under
checking d6 yeah I can go for this this
kind of structure I have got the
fantastic piece there on see form while
it's bishop is kind of not doing that
much I could have played fy5 that was
stronger even ok it's not a problem
really but it that was stronger doing
that immediately and now we can template
to quickly i play too much bullet
yesterday I played a little bit of
bullet yesterday and I'm just playing
too quickly him but he did not take all
your new one for some strange reason hmm
did not take them not quite sure why
okay yeah maybe this is possible as well
checking checking here my back rank is
an issue definitely is okay going to
secure my back rank if he goes look at
aveda have Queen g3 and then chief on d6
yeah yeah I can do the same thing check
i think i was always getting something
back but I definitely didn't play it in
the best possible way pretty sure about
that okay if I take with the night he
has f4 possibly taking with the Queen
it's not really that great okay my chick
with the night f form reform queen of 26
yeah that's not good I have ever really
miss played that unfortunately it might
still be okay but it isn't isn't really
great
yeah if he takes I think I'm okay i will
take on that five with the night and d5
is secured due to the sound fork okay
just drops back okay this is a good end
game right time morning maybe I should
have checked aware of something bad of
it this is just simple and good having
them great pawn down and his a king is
cut off yeah that's whack right I am
this is just a winner going to approach
with the king and let the deep on
promote I still feel I I played it badly
I mean here this position is really nice
and I probably could have improved on
several occasions so this is okay the
comp points out rupee oneness better or
bishop g3 but ok this is a normal human
move let's say here ok computer wants to
go bishop age form yeah I didn't really
calculate in much detail here I was just
seeing that this is an advantage and
then I didn't look the comp our verse
has it's not so great to take stakes
1973 and now it wants to play Knight b6
with only a slight advantage that's
possible i haven't that's really
possible 95 was quite accommodating i
think and i don't agree with the comp
evaluation of being of this position
being equal I really don't at least a
few we talked about human players I
don't think this is equal and I even
have a an objective doubt about that my
night is a perfect locator here many end
games will be good and his King is not
very secure I played I played this move
really quickly and as I should have
considered this one ready and then f5
that was what was much stronger yeah the
comps s equal yeah maybe Queenie form
maybe Queenie Falls really orc we need
to well let's pasa
his King looks weak but I cannot really
attack it at the moment yeah I agreed
that descends definitely the case okay
then this is probably the counter play
that I I did not really appreciate
correctly and the comp evaluation might
be okay yeah and this is here I mean if
I this is just weird but maybe it's just
about chat is just about about working
yeah so computers has equal well okay
check and queen d 6 that looks okay and
no here yeah yeah i'm just-just very
much better the computer wants to trade
and go here are interesting and claims
this is equal yeah okay well he's got
two points so this is interesting my
pony on and the default is dangerous but
he has to too dangerous passes maybe
that's equal maybe computers has 0 0 0
pin but this is definitely not working
now i can take and this is this is
almost an automatic win because i have a
very clear plan g for King up and then
the deep on and there's really not much
that he can do if he offers the rook
trade I'm happy to take and then I'm
going to walk up with the king note that
all those squares are protected he has
no way to enter my position i'm just
about in time to play this and then
we'll promote well that's it some viet
arrows and I'm ready to promote the deep
on so that wasn't a very clean game but
well the first game of a sesh is always
a bit term a bit shaky yes by experience
okay well thanks for watching